the nose to the left 430 to the nose to
the left 391 the nose to the left
344 3 times put two about three times
lost Boris Johnson now wants to succeed
where Theresa May failed not to the
haggling today with the DUP and hoping
that keeps the bricks of tears at the
ERG on board too but even if he wins
both a majority of - 45 means number 10
must chase support from across the
spectrum from what we're hearing if it's
correct that the government's strategy
is all about divergence and the
political declaration on the future
relationship will is not going to have
those guarantees and safeguards that
we're looking for then I think it
becomes more difficult for Labour MPs to
support it
so does Boris Johnson have the numbers
in the Commons to get a brexit deal
through there are 650 MPs but only 639
of them vote so the Prime Minister needs
320 MPs to vote for his plan on Saturday
in order to have a majority all
conservative MPs can realistically be
expected to vote for it
so that's 287 as can the DUP after
last-minute haggling that takes you to
297 MPs in favor so where does he find
the rest to get him over the line
remember all Lib Dems SNP Green Clyde
and change UK MPs which is 64 will vote
against and almost all Labour MPs around
226 a set to vote against it bringing
that side to a total of 290 but there
are three groups of mp's Downing Street
is desperate to win support from to get
the deal over the line there's the 19
Labour MPs who've hinted they might
support a Johnson deal and the 20 Tories
who lost the whip and haven't yet
defected to another party as well as
some of the 13 other independents who
largely quit labour they're up for grabs
Downing Street have been trying to get
MPs like this one onside who lost the
Tory whip last month over a No Deal
rebellion getting them all voting with
the PM is not proving so easy
on a straight up-and-down vote on Boris
Johnson's deal will you support it how
many of the others in the 21 will
support it well if it was a straight up
and down deal
no I would not because I'm absolutely
committed to the concept of any deal
being put back to the people I think
there are some of us of within the 21
who share my view on that committee it's
difficult to say this point in time but
I think I was saved between six and
eight it's definitely of the view that
we should have a referendum on any deal
possible labor support wobbling up to
eight former Tories rebelling and
intense negotiations with the DEP and
the ERG to hunt them close if a deal is
ever done in Brussels it will come down
to a tiny handful of MPs to determine
whether or not this ever gets through
the Commons Sam go to Sky News